hello and welcome to gamespot after dark
episode 157 probably
i'm your host tomorrow and i am joined
by
john luccepke hi
you are i was waiting for you to sit
down sorry you uh were muted for a sec
it didn't it didn't trigger the thing i
was i was muted hell yeah
that's just a video it's only for video
people it's the audio listening take
that video
people it's a new setup i had to rewire
the studio to make this happen
we appreciate it and then on the last
minute multiple of us were like we're
not coming in
[Laughter]
my cat's gonna [ __ ] everywhere i would
rather do it while i'm home you know
just bring them in here just [ __ ] all
over the studio
yeah maybe maybe if if your cat shot
enough on the table they'd have to get
rid of it yes
oh that's a great girl that's a great
idea that's a great idea we also joined
was not joined by jake decker
hello uh yeah we got to get some cat
[ __ ] on this table let's get it the [ __ ]
out of here
lucy james
apparently purveyor of cat [ __ ] at the
moment hi exactly and we've got a
special guest gerard khalil aka the
completionist
hello
i'm doing great thank you for having me
i'm i'm stoked to talk to you guys it's
so cool because uh i didn't know you
guys a few months ago and now i feel
like i know all you so well it's so
exciting to be here so thanks for having
me yeah it is kind of weird like we've
rapidly all become like super super
close friends over the course of what
like three months but hung out together
yeah and like spent a lot of time
together it's like
yeah
you don't you don't uh
you don't forget a moment like that yeah
you never forget you don't you never
forget
watching jake valdino almost cry
yeah
yeah this is
this is my first time meeting you and i
have not done any of this so i feel like
just kind of emotionally
there will always be more chances to eat
curry together that's true it just means
that we're going to have to schedule a
meeting next time and have the podcast
at kokuichimana let's just tell you
every member of gamespot [ __ ] asleep
just an hour and a half of just us all
sleeping on a couch that's beautiful
it's perfect
content actually actually sleep sleep
streams are now against tos on twitch
sadly yeah we're learning so much about
twitch
yeah
i've spent a lot of time learning about
twitch tos because i've been trying to
figure out where the lines are so i can
get between them
um
obviously uh we're going to be talking a
lot about video games and what we've
been playing but before we get into that
i want to talk to gerard obviously we've
got you here you are
number one video gamer
in the world in many corners of the
world you're literally called the
completionist you make it your job to
complete games but you're also a host on
g4
and you have been working on something
very very cool that i would love to talk
about just because it's something that
you don't see getting made very much
these days but it's something that used
to happen a lot back in the day
um you're making a tv not a tv series
what is tv series but like an ongoing
series
called god of work which is exactly what
it sounds like tell us about it
yeah so uh god of work is it's
technically a tv series because it's
airing on on cable if you've got g4
uh and yeah it's it's super exciting uh
i i
infamously say that i i bullied my way
into making this show and it's true i
really i really
uh i mean that's how kratos would do it
that's that's what i figured right
that's that's how he would do it if he
was to make a tv show kratos would just
harass everyone around him whether it's
you know sexually or verbally he just
would get what he wants because he's
kratos the god of war and so uh you know
uh i convinced my my my fellow producers
at g4
to uh take a chance with me on this show
and uh emily rose uh said yes anne to me
so much with this whole show we got the
writers together and the producers and
we we made a a we shot
100 pages in in five days back to back
we shot a whole film
in in in our studio and it was it was a
very chaotic process but uh
we're almost here uh we're gonna be
debuting it uh in in
about two or three weeks provide you
know we'll have dates very very soon but
it's it's really exciting man you know
tim i think you you just said something
that's that's super important to me i
grew up on that early 2000 odds internet
of college humor and cracked and these
these places that made you know web
series chad vader used to be something i
used to watch all the time right and so
i was gonna bring up chad vader because
it gives me very chad vader vibes which
makes me yeah extremely happy
i'm so glad you you picked up on that uh
so to me this is this is you know it
seemed like when the office came out
everyone was doing an office parody
right everyone was doing their whole
thing and so it just seemed like the
right time
to pitch a crazy idea for a show and uh
you know the show really is
what you know the idea of it is where do
video game characters go in between
games if we all think that video game
characters are actors that get paid to
to make a video game and that's their
daytime job when they're not making a
game
what do they do and so this show is
about a place called digital solutions
the uh solutions of today tomorrow
yesterday and it's all about how video
game characters work at this temp agency
hoping that they get their next game
greenlit and so
uh kratos uh is kind of the office bully
that just gets what he wants and
terrorizes everyone and
no one's afraid to say
uh no to him because he's the god of war
so that's kind of the whole part of the
show it's it's
it's just me
being angry at everyone it's fun
you know every time you talk about it i
remember a different 90s 2000 era like
online show that it reminds me of do you
remember terry crews office linebacker
yes
this just reminded me of that this is
the first thing that i knew terry crews
from where he'd just be in an office but
as a linebacker so like every now and
again when someone did something shitty
in the office like someone's lunch got
stolen he would just tackle the [ __ ]
person to the ground
um
before we get too much uh we'll discuss
a bit more about it but am i right in
thinking jean-luc that we will be able
to show the fine folks watching a
trailer going into position so john
looks moving into position so he's
getting ready he's getting ready
we've got a trailer and an exclusive
clip just for you guys here
what do you think we should start with
we're seeing
yeah uh
ooh
i say
let's start with the trailer just to let
everyone feel like the vibe of the show
and then afterwards we'll we can
showcase the clip okay apologies to
audio listeners this will not be yeah
if you're listening you're not going to
if you're listening via audio go on
google god of work watch the trailer
you'll have a great time okay
[Music]
so your journey begins mortal
welcome to ragnarok yeah
merry restaurant
do it you coward
i've been at digital solutions for seven
years
dream job unlocks
[Music]
but you work here long enough and the
benefits start really stacking up at
least that's what they tell me
kratos burritos
that was great i have a question for you
gerard
yeah
how soon did you decide that you were
going to be the god of worker the team
decided that you were going to play
kratos because obviously there's a
striking resemblance that you have but
was there ever a phase where you were
auditioning i just
i just cannot imagine a scenario i know
god pictures this and people standing
next to him
with his beard someone goes maybe we
should get that white guy
looking white guys
scott the wizard he seems like a good
fit
scott the walls as kratos hey y'all
kratos here
yeah i uh
you know
when i pitched the show
i i immediately said i will play kratos
because for two reasons one uh i'm gonna
sit in a chair and be in makeup for five
hours a day i knew
that no one in their right mind would
want to sit down in a chair and do
makeup from 6am until you know 11
o'clock noon right that's how long you
had to be in the chair for yeah it
depended on on the day and
and our shooting schedule and whatnot
but uh my call time was 6 a.m i was in
makeup uh until 10 11 noon depending
because
you know we are a studio so as we're
filming all these other projects and god
of work was the priority i'd have three
makeup artists working on me at any
given moment and they'd have to break
away for a little bit and go work on
this shoot or that shoot and then come
back and work on me and uh and then when
we would do that eventually it was like
great uh now the makeup's falling apart
because uh you know my makeup is
smearing because it's hot
and it's hot as hell um the second thing
is that uh i have done a lot of you know
not only people know this but uh i've
been performing on stage in film and
theater for years uh 15 plus years of
experience and uh i have dealt with my
fair share of bald caps bald caps never
look good they never work they always
fall apart and so the minute that i said
we're gonna do this i turned everyone
said i'm shaving my head
i'm gonna shave my head completely bald
and so what you see in the trailer is
not a bald cap i did in fact shave my
head uh and it it it grew back pretty
quickly all things considered i feel
like i'm oh wow i'm getting i'm getting
there finally wild how quickly it grew
back because we were doing like fps and
stuff and one one week you came in and
you were bold and then two weeks later
you had like yeah you were fine like
i actually think
you got those brown people jeans that's
why oh yeah oh yeah you sent an image to
the fps chat of you like i did something
and it was just a selfie with you
looking like a kratos
uh yeah i was gonna say um
how did you cast the rest of the other
characters in this because we see like
mario's in here we've got link in there
how did you did people would be like i
want to be linked or i want to be how
did it come
so uh truth be told how we wrote the
script is we wrote it in a way where
no character was specific outside of
kratos being the main character there
are some episodes that theme around
certain video game characters like for
instance we have a loi aloe
from horizon you saw
actually abby russell from formerly a
giant bomb in g4 uh she she plays eloy
um in an episode and so we have some
characters that kind of pop in and out
but uh mario and luigi are the head of
janitorial for the office so obviously
they have to clean up after everyone um
and uh yeah you know
we we kind of said hey once we have the
core characters established in this
world we kind of told everyone in the
office hey if you want to be in the show
go get a costume or or go bring in
something and so we had a few folks who
cosplay just because we're all a bunch
of nerds in the office and so you know
we have ezio auditore in the in the cast
we have um
uh
scorpion for mortal kombat so uh you
know obviously link is a staple in the
g4
uh pantheon drunk link is always
somewhere in in geforce essence of
x-play so we tried really hard to to
really make it about kratos and some of
the more immediate characters that
affect him in the plot but everyone else
is kind of background dressing that we
just said hey if you want to be in the
show pitch us with who you want to be
and why and and we'll try and get a
costume for you or
if you've got one please bring it in
this is obviously going to be a major
success and it's going to there's going
to be a season two and i would like to
pitch for a character on season two okay
sure i'm ready if you say mika lash
tomorrow no no okay
no no
nikolas is a good one but i got
something better here's the thing right
imagine the scene you're having
a normal scene play out okay it's the
office maybe you're at lunch and then
suddenly from the corner of your eyes a
red phantom emerges out of nowhere and
just starts hunting everyone in the
office
i could be a red dark souls phantom just
[ __ ] everything up and then i just
leave
i just like do my little wave and leave
how about it that's our crows that just
bothered the building is that we just
get dark souls invaders like they're
damn it someone gets a broom but
all you say is hello hello
very good and then i just like i'll roll
through some computers and then leave
just
g4 hr like who broke all these [ __ ]
expensive computers
is there a red red phone
yeah can i be a sim
where i just kind of like there's a mild
inconvenience in my way and i just stand
and like freak out like this because i
can't step over things
and then i just keep missing the i miss
the uh the carpool into work every day
because i get stuck
um
and then she's just on the couch
yeah and grow old and die within 10
minutes
somehow
or you go to the bathroom and we delete
the door and then you're stuck yeah
oh yeah i'm just in a swimming pool
like we'll write it in there's a
swimming pool
i'm sure g4 can install the swimming
pool yeah easy yeah no problem right no
problem with that
uh that's jonathan i'm amazed you didn't
go for snake by the way
a snake yeah i i snake would be good but
no one no one needs to see my cheeks on
the show um john luke do you wanna play
the exclusive clip that we've got for
for god of work i'm ready to go
should i should i should i set up the
stage a little bit
so in this particular scene um this
episode is about kratos birthday
and uh he's had a few drinks
and uh the office is a mess
and uh that's all you need to know for
what you're going to see okay
krios it's like passing a gorgon eye ah
elizabeth have you ever heard of a
spartan steamer we need to talk i'll be
out in the squeeze
no christopher
you stay
it is too late for you now
i don't want to talk about it
every tv show needs a good like pissing
[ __ ] and farting scene which
uh this this definitely has that's
you've embodied that character yeah
yeah we uh we we had to just incorporate
i i when we were doing that i was i
i think i i improv the line about the
gorgon eye just because i thought that
was such a
weird thing from from god of war the
originals that were like so important
for kratos um
but yeah man the show is crazy we just
uh our writers are so talented uh
zipper jacob and uh and emily just they
just said hey we're gonna go balls to
the walls and see what happens and i
think we said yes to almost every idea
there's so many crazy things here um
xavier woods plays himself from wwe the
2k series and uh there's a bit of a joke
about how like
the games were buggy so we were kind of
nervous like which game is he from is he
from
he's from he's from the new one so we
all like we're like oh thank god like it
could have been worse uh yeah so yeah
there's just a lot of fun little moments
like that that you know uh we paid very
close attention to
there's a lot of easter eggs if you know
a lot of lore about games and and
relationships with characters you try
really hard to make it subtle but really
fun
the big question is
have you heard or anything from sony
about this
absolutely not um
i
i have been nothing from corey barlog at
all endemus garina i don't know if if
corey barlock knows i exist let alone
cares that i exist oh you're surprised
if he watches this or if anyone knows
him uh i don't know we know it
i would i would love to have him cameo
in season two uh i know that it's a
little contentious obviously that like
we are it's a parody it's satire it's
not real we're not promoting the fact
that like this is an official sony
production it is a sketch series we
didn't get the licenses for anything but
it's considered parody it's obviously
ingest um but i i'd love to have corey
appear in season two as a tiny cameo
if i if i know anything about corey is
that he's got a very good sense of humor
so i i bet you even even the other day
when someone made that god of war like
ripoff game he quoted
[Laughter]
at the very least we can make sure that
he sees it
i hope so i i i hope at the very least
uh you know i hope that i don't know if
anyone from santa monica studios is
watching this but um
we made this show as a tribute to you
guys and the and the games that you've
made whether it's the first game whether
it's chains of olympus or whether it's
uh the most recent one and of course
ragnarok right around the corner we made
this as a love letter to you guys in the
wonderful world you created and and the
wonderful character right because the
whole point of this show is
kratos went from the original god of war
games to being this like empathetic
loving father and and
and and really bonding with his his son
to then just being an out of control
rock star that doesn't care about
anything or anyone he's overweight he
doesn't care he he sleeps with anyone he
wants he bullies everyone he gets what
he what he wants because that's how
kratos has always lived his life and so
uh you're seeing a very hollywood
version of kratos as if he just is a
hollywood actor which is you know what
we really wanted to kind of uh have fun
with so i hope everyone enjoys the show
yeah it looks really cool really really
fun um you don't have a an exact airing
day premiere date yet have you uh i i i
do but i'm telling you i'll say
i will say it's going to air in august
and it's only what two more weeks of
august so
very soon uh very very very soon yo if
you follow me on twitter or social media
you'll see that i'm going to be doing
probably
images of posters and and
other trailers and moments just to kind
of ramp up the whole thing the one thing
i can say though it's very exciting is
that um this will debut uh on tv
um normally through through the g4
network on cable um over the course of
several weeks um but if you want to
watch the whole thing when it does come
out the whole season will be available
on my youtube channel on launch day so
that way if you want to watch the entire
show you don't want to wait you can
watch it all in one go uh and then it'll
be released on other services and
platforms uh sporadically over the
course of the next few weeks
so go to youtube and search for the
completionist and subscribe if you
haven't already and you'll be able to
watch it there or catch it on tv yeah
you know you know i just thought about
how amazing would it be if somebody did
another one of those you know those for
the gamers adverts where it's like
here is uh like slow panning across a
room where nathan drake's scarf is and
then you see like sac boy running past
do another one of those but when the god
of war bit comes out it's just gerard's
god of war versions
[Laughter]
chad vader that guy he did vader so well
that lucas actually hired him to do the
voice of darth vader in uh the force uh
force unleashed i think it was so like
hey you know sony might
they could hit you up they could be like
he's a good kratos let's get him in
that third third god of war game god of
war
fight for
midgard or whatever they call it
could be you if uh if what's his name
isn't isn't available what's his name
again christopher judge christopher
judge
oh my god judge we lost
that meaning
is oh you hate to see it the funny thing
about that is i it does there is no
battery pack it's literally
it's just literally it's literally
plugged in yeah yeah
that would happen to me i'm just over
here um yeah so make sure you check out
god of work um we're gonna play a little
game later on where we try and cast the
office characters as video game
characters but we'll come back to that
later before we get there we're going to
check in on everyone and what they've
been playing
um let's start with our guest gerard
what you've been playing recently oh man
as far as new stuff um i just started
playing uh spider-man on on my steam
deck
i have joined i have joined the special
team of people who own a steam deck
i might scratch to us give ourselves a
pound
yes let's go we did it
i got pushed back to q4 so
well because
i was i was q1 2023 and then suddenly
was catapulted
just to a day
don't know what someone someone tweeted
me earlier to ask where i was up to in
the queue if i was still q3 and he said
oh i didn't get my uh thing yet and it
took me like an hour to reply and he
went oh that's so funny because in this
hour i got my email and i was like i'm a
happy i'm happy thank you
it is
not spent too much time on the steam
deck but it is interesting how valve has
been rolling it out i know part of it
has to do with just shortages of
materials that they need but i feel like
every time a new wave comes out it feels
like an event of of haves and have-nots
i i feel personally victimized by gabe
newton i do i do that yeah absolutely
but
i i feel like it's really helping their
marketing that just every couple months
you know like i don't know how many
people get these each way but every
couple months you just see a bunch of
people post on twitter their brand new
steam deck and every time i'm like you
[ __ ] give it to me
[Laughter]
gerard the question i have for you is
how much vampire survivors have you
played on steam deck
um
okay okay so before i got my steam deck
i was at 140 hours
uh i got my steam deck two weeks ago
i am now at 227 hours
i i've completed as much as i can
because there's no more content left but
i've got every character i've got every
thing unlocked every achievement so far
um
i'm just every day i wait it's my it's
my rubik's cube game i wake up and i
need to wake up i turn my steam deck on
i look at it you know with my coffee and
i'm just doing a quick round and i get
to the point where i'm able to
eight minutes in just set the steam deck
down and watch the gold pile up and just
walk away it's that easy well
i'm not saying much but
as a vampire survivor's influencer
he was the one who influenced me we're
gonna go we're gonna do this because
even before lucy brought it up i put it
on the first run sheet for fps i put
vampire survivors
because you were like
months months maybe not months but weeks
before lucy had seen it so i'm just
saying you know okay i'm the one who
told lucy so i i was playing this when
it like first came out and me and mike
were chatting about it from back in the
day but
gerard i would say prepare yourself to
play a lot more vampire survivors soon
wait
wait till you discover the pokemon mod
for vampire survivors is that is that
true interesting i think so how does
that work
yeah yeah um but that game on on steam
deck is just
so good it's so annoyingly good i
i feel like it eventually will come to
switch i'm sure but as of now
because it's on the steam deck it's all
i play
night and day it's so good all right and
it does it just first it just doesn't
get old i'm i'm plugged in
yeah uh but you're playing spider-man
did you say less less good game but yeah
yeah i guess
i i well since you know it's a less good
game everything compared to vampire
survivors is lesser all right um
yeah i've been really enjoying it so far
it's been um
you know
the thing i've been struggling with the
steam deck and i don't know if
those teammates out there agree or not
i'm even though games are steam deck
ready i feel like i'm never getting the
right resolution or the right usage out
of my steam deck so like i started
playing god of war uh 2018 on my steam
deck it didn't look
great i i spent like at least 30 minutes
tweaking it to make it look exactly as i
thought it would look good um and i kind
of feel like and hopefully there's a way
to do this it's just like an optimize
button you just press it and like boom
right resolution right frame rate right
settings
to just work uh yeah it's it's kind of
that classic is in every way a portable
pc to the point where you have to
finesse these things a bit there are
some games that just know the right
settings and will work um but i think
like it tends to be the more powerful
like games that tend to overreach yeah
and they and they end up being like a
bit weird like but some smaller games
will do that as well um i was playing
cult of the lamb on it and
by default it's it looks fine but then i
realized everything looks kind of small
and kind of weird like so and then i
messed around with the resolution a bit
and then it now it looks way better so
like in almost all cases like it is
worth tinkering with it because
sometimes settings will be on that you
just can't see and all you're really
doing by leaving it on is just draining
the battery at double speed yeah um so
yeah there is a little bit of like
finesse this to make it work i get i
would love something that will be like
because they do that for the controls
right like when you download a game if
there's like a control profile that they
know is super good it just autoloads
that yeah so i hope they come up with an
alternative mode or an alternative to
that or a version of that for display
things yeah a lot of those control stuff
that's like community made too like so
you can like make your own like hey i
think these are the best you know
controls so maybe they could do like a
community like hey i spent the time and
i these are the optimized settings and
people that vote it because they agree
and then yeah that'd be a good way to
handle that i think
is this does this only happen with games
that aren't like deck ready isn't it
aren't games certain games deck ready
they're just yeah decorating decorative
games yeah the decorative games are the
ones that are usually from the get-go
when you hit play they're all like
optimized and good to go okay so those
you don't need to mess with really you
don't really like a little bit well for
for a little bit for spider-man and god
of war i had to mess with it a fair
amount no just because it wasn't even
though it says it was steam deck ready
like i was getting weird hiccups and and
frame radiation oh yeah i think it's
like when their brand
i mean like doesn't work for god of war
but spider-man just came out and that
game is constantly being updated but
like some games like i did elden ring
when it came out it was deck ready and
it was like perfect good to go from the
outside i didn't have to change anything
yeah um so i guess like mileage may vary
yeah like a weird example with
spider-man specifically is the the frame
rate in that game likes to
swing uh pretty wildly uh back and forth
um so like you'll be like running around
the open world and it'll like fluctuate
between like 35 and like 45 and it's a
really
unpleasant experience to play so
uh yeah what you need to do is you need
to lock
the frame rate to 30 but
for some reason the in-game settings um
like it has an option but it does not
work on the steam deck it's just like
disabled so you actually have to go into
the steam decks like uh performance
setting and like enable like lock this
to 30. so it's like a weird workaround
that
like i kind of wish by like yeah like by
default the game would be like hey
you should probably play it at 30 you
can't really hit 60 in this game on the
steam deck so like we'll go ahead and do
that before you like because otherwise
people wouldn't know and they would just
be like oh this kind of just
hurts my eyes i play
i danny penna and i both have the same
issue of like every noun the screen goes
black when you're swinging
oh did you ever have that no that was
yeah they patched it out already and
fixed it but like when we were playing
it and we just were both like what the
hell like every now and then used to be
swinging through new york and then
suddenly you would hear the swinging
yeah
i mean they already patched it so
yeah they are like they've put a lot
into that game and
i think it's on them now to kind of
tweak it um especially for spider-man
because as we know with great power
must come great responsibility
if jake if you get a steam deck i think
you should start a series called uh
steam decker and just keep there it is
just doing loads of videos
about the steam deck that's what i want
hey that's that's what the audience
wants i hear they want steam deck
content so uh from yeah just just type
in just at a valve and be like hey the
audience wants me to do steam content
one now
i'm the i'm uniquely positioned because
of my surname to do this content
um but you're enjoying uh spider-man on
steam deck interrupt
yeah i think
definitely i think the thing that i'm
i've definitely realized though is that
uh
we just had miles morales not too long
ago and then bef and ps4 or ps5 remaster
of spider-man so i always i
it's the third time that i've downloaded
spider-man and started playing it and so
i was like this is so exciting i'm ready
to play spider-man on the steam deck
for the third time in less than
less than three years
yeah three years
you ready to stop those crimes in
progress again
remember to collect those backpacks
yeah right yeah
yeah i will say that like playing it on
the go though at least like did kind of
rejuvenate my feelings like a little bit
because it's just like absolutely i'm
hanging out on the couch i'm all like
cuddled up or you know uh like playing
in the office on lunch
i like that you were like playing on the
go has uh really rejuvenated me i'm all
hanging out on the couch and cuddled up
well like your hand there's something
like i don't know it's like that uh i
feel like that's why this uh switch is
so popular because there's just
something about like
even if you're still in your house
you're just like yeah but it's in my
hand i can cool i can't play i can poop
and swing around at the same time
i mean i do that all the time without
playing that game
oh yeah yeah
yeah uh-huh it's it's like it's like
shooting freeze
from half court that's how i approach
taking a [ __ ]
downtown
just flinging them your bathroom is not
that big okay
what does spider-man do when he has to
go like on when he's like swinging
around how does he
wait
the speed he's traveling he could easily
[ __ ] just squat one out with his
pants he's like in the air and then be
like no one's gonna know like i'll be
gone the moment that comes out of his
arse it's already so far away from him
that there's no way anyone pins it away
from him
the daily bugles just like get me
pictures of spider-man [ __ ] dammit
yeah
jonah jameson showing up here polka i
need pictures of spiderman shing and
he's like
that doesn't sound doable man there's
nobody that's out there for it damn it
the phantom [ __ ] rise again
uh but yeah anything else you're playing
trod
oh that's it just spiderman vampire
survivors
mostly vampire survivors lovely you'd
love to see it
jean-luc what you been up to
uh most of my time was actually
spider-man on steam deck
as well
and then
i otherwise i just keep playing bear and
breakfast um i'm just trying to grind
out that uh that end game
uh area pine fall i think it's called um
they yeah they they they patched they've
been continually patching it um the
patch notes are really cute on on uh
steam uh like
they like apologize for like misspelling
um
blueberries blackberry and they're like
they're like fruits are hard okay and
i'm like oh it's okay i understand it's
fine um i don't understand
no never let it happen again i was
talking to callie about it and she she's
also um used to be uh reviews into her
games and she was just like i love this
game so much but i want to copy edit it
yeah
i had to turn my brain off for that
there are like i'll
never make it through this game there
are two times where they said west or
east instead of west so they're like you
need to go east and i'm like
and i was like looking on the east side
of the map and i was like i don't know
where to go and then i like checked the
other side and i was like oh
that that's a mistake oops that's a
bummer
yeah video game developers if you need
copy editing hit me up okay
cringe check
i can do apparently my gaming services
are copy editing and cringe checking if
you need someone to check if your
writing is cringe i will do it for free
okay wow free yeah yeah
he does it for me all the time not a
tweet goes out from my account
that hasn't been cringe checked
exactly so how many
how many of your tweets actually make it
out then that's why she hasn't tweeted
in ages
[Laughter]
uh
jake what have you been playing
i
i've been playing pub g actually which
has been weird
why is everyone playing games from 10
years ago i mean there is another game
i'm playing but i can't talk about it
i've been playing pub g because
i'm i read the art of war and i'm trying
to see if it makes me better at games
pubg pub g made the most sense
i'm doing a whole video i'm doing a
whole video it'll be good i promise okay
okay yeah yeah yeah you hadn't even said
it was for a video i know you just said
i could have gone with it gerard looks
so confused he's like what the [ __ ]
it's the most
it was that because what it sounded like
was like you were basically going yeah
i've got these coffee beans that i
imported from this one specific country
of video games that's what you were
saying right now
um
yeah so i'm doing a video for it but i
landed on pub g because
a lot of the tactics seem to make a lot
of sense that could actually work in pub
g but that said yeah i've been playing
pub g which has been weird because that
game
it was one of my favorites when it came
out but it has been passed by every
other
battle royale at this point that said
getting kills in that game is still the
most satisfying in any battle royale
game it's just
apex legends
jordan's not here to defend to defend
apex legends i like apex legends though
but getting kills in apex legends not
the same as getting kills in pub g same
with fortnite same with warzone they
just they just don't quite hit
in terms of quality of life though all
those games beat out pubg by a lot but
but it's been interesting revisiting
pubg because it's been a very long time
and i i kind of like how
that game still to this day
is he in chat
i like how jordan you're supposed to be
writing a review i will not tell you
again yeah jordan come on
uh i like how pubg doesn't feel focus
tested though
it feels like a mess in a good way yeah
uh like the maps don't really make a lot
i mean the new ones make a little more
sense but replaying the original map is
just
someone threw houses on a map there's no
roads that lead to half these houses
houses are missing rooms that should be
there uh
and it seems incomprehensible but when
you're actually playing it it kind of
works and adds to this weird
pubg universe that used to include
calypso protocol but now it doesn't
include calypso protocol so
i don't know
take what you will should you go back to
play pubg probably not but i've been
oddly enjoying it and maybe it's because
i've read the art of war a couple times
and now i'm good at it all right
yeah that's it i've read
i've read the olive oil a couple times
it's it's like it's like a 20 minute
read yeah it is it is pretty yeah it's
like i took notes for one of them took
longer
someone who has read the olive oil a
couple of times it's not very good okay
it's not very exciting
it doesn't have a lot of good
information in there how many people who
read the article
teenage teenage boys at some point in
their life that once they hit puberty
the next stage of development is reading
the art of war
i thought it was just being on
encyclopedia dramatica but maybe just
teenage girls i mean that that too but
like um art of war comes first
uh
yeah pubg is such a
weird game like every time i look at it
i'm like this is
the grossest looking game like every
time i look at it it's like actively
uninviting it's also
so broken still yeah
i can't play the new map it crashes to
desktop every time i try and load the
new map they've released eight maps now
it's been
six years or whatever sometimes i'll get
like a like a loot box and it opens up
and the image is just not there so it's
just like a square gray box and i'm like
oh cool really stoked about this gray
box i got i have no idea what it is
meanwhile
player unknown is [ __ ] in the wind
right now he's like i'm out of here i
need my money oh yeah brendan green
where are you he left a while ago right
did he yeah yeah do you remember when
you got a picture of him doing vape yeah
me and him we had an interview where we
just talked about vaping the entire time
it was like so weird
he's brendan not brandon yeah it's
brandon he he got a new game studio and
he started working on something else and
then just not heard from him since
if i believe if i'm at cricket what are
you going to say there just say one of
the big reasons why fortnite and all
those other
you know battle royales took off is
because how ugly and unoptimized pubg
was
yeah like that truly is the
i guarantee you more than half the
player base of fortnight's like what's a
pub g
oh yeah yeah
no clue yeah yeah and the thing is like
i don't know those those those are like
janky
versions of the games that other people
have more popular i still have such a
massive
fan base like people still play rust and
rust is a [ __ ] catastrophe of a video
game love rust they love rust every time
i go in rust i'm like this was created
by blind mice a hundred percent it's
just a mess in there like it's so weird
i think
the interesting thing about pub g though
is is i i
a lot of people did but i was really
into pub g when it came out so i watched
the
i don't want to say fall people love to
dramatize things like the rise and fall
of pub g but i watched it go to these
meteoric heights and then fortnight and
i remember a quote i think from brendan
green was like oh yeah we're not worried
about fortnite and then fortnite
overtook it and then they tried to sue
fortnite and it was like no you you you
dropped the ball here and then when pub
g started to not not lose some interest
i would say they added a battle pass
that was their solution and it was just
like no no one wants this [ __ ] like
they want a game that's optimized and
works
yeah anyway that's my tirade on pub g
wait hang on uh spawn on me so hi kelly
if you're in the chat it's not the best
the best gray boxes
in pubg
yeah i guess so
the best grey boxes everything else just
a waking nightmare apart from the the
shooting the shooting is good though
that's what matters and the weird
physics sometimes i remember like
playing that game and the weird physics
would be like
okay i'm guessing i guess i'm not
playing this game anymore because i'm
like hit a rock
running towards the weapon and suddenly
i'm inside a tractor on the other side
of my i'm like all right cool i guess i
am this bathtub now great um but yeah
lucy what you've been playing i am the
tub i mean i was always the top but you
know
um
new game that's what i've been playing
finally
a real gamer well i was gonna say well
so last week i couldn't talk about sound
man because the embargo was one minute
past midnight on friday but uh i did
obviously watch all that uh but i've
been playing a lot of cults of the lamb
recently which is a fantastic game that
just makes my lizard brain so so happy
because it also kind of it's it's a
management sim
but it's also kind of
um you know
dungeon crawling killing guys i'm
playing it on easy just because i can't
really be bothered to do so i know i'm
not a gamer i'm sorry i would like to
rescind my earlier statement
[Music]
i'm kidding you can play on whatever you
want okay no i just i i've been
struggling a lot with my repetitive
strain recently and i can't do uh that
like sorry audio listeners i can't just
button bash to because the combat is
pretty simple it's just like i'm playing
on um
using a controller
and like x2 hit and then why you have
special it's very it's like pretty easy
to get into grips with and it's just
so satisfying because every single time
you are just you're just rewarded with
everything it's really really cute my
cult is called cult of the jams
i'm getting i'm getting to the point now
where my cult i've built them up pretty
well it's a pretty well self-sustaining
uh it's a colony that's pretty much
self-sustaining but now a lot of my guys
are dying
and i have to go out and get new ones
because i need to live
in the life that i've become accustomed
to as a cult leader
and it makes me it makes me do [ __ ] up
things like
sometimes they'll just ask to be
sacrificed or they'll ask to eat a bowl
of [ __ ] yep and i'm just like that's
totally fine okay you want to do this i
don't feel good about doing it but i
guess i will i got annoyed the other day
because i couldn't um get tithes from
the older
cult members
and i was like why can i only why can i
only extort the younger members of my
cult for money and then i was like oh
that's a pretty [ __ ] up way you're
thinking about it but it's a great day
it's it's a lot of fun it's always
always stuff is going up all this stuff
is going up i'm always leveling up
either my cult members are becoming more
devoted to me or i have gathered enough
faith and devotion to unlock something
else i'm building stuff there's a
farming sim aspect to it so i'm always
growing things and getting things i'm
planting things
fishing mini game stuff to collect
and and then you know that's even before
because i can i can get lost just doing
it um
just doing the management stuff even
before you go into the dungeon crawling
bit but it's so fun it's really
interesting because like the more i play
it the more i realize like
there's the kind of dungeon crawling
combat side of it and the management
side of it are slightly disjointed from
each other they're not like super
there's not like a perfect loop through
each one where one is symbiotically
feeding into the other and back and
forth it's kind of like you go into one
part of it and that lets you get a few
things and then you can do it in the
other one it's kind of like
it doesn't feel as smooth as you might
expect it to be but each part of it is
so satisfying that you just don't care
you're just like i don't i don't really
care like i just the combat side of it
is like not to not to
like um
[ __ ] on any other games but like uh
tunic i think it was there was a part of
tunic that just didn't feel right to me
in terms of the combat every other part
of tunic is pretty amazing but in terms
of playing it i wasn't super into it um
but with this game there's something a
little more satisfying about it and i
think that comes from the kind of
randomized nature of it where when you
go into a dungeon
the weapons that you get they're kind of
like hades they just randomly spawn
based on like a selection that you have
access to and you get like a weapon and
then you get like a spell of some sort
and each time yeah each time it occurs
yeah each time it's like you don't know
what you're going to get and it's fun to
like look at the weapon that you got and
you'll be like how do i make this work
for me and it's kind of like that same
feeling that you get when you play a
call of duty or i know a moba and you
pick a character and just like let me
try and figure this out a bit and see
how it goes and it takes you like two or
three rooms to get into the groove of it
but once you get into the groove that
you're like hell yeah i understand how
to use this thing it's kind of like
figuring out a fighting game character
um and that's like super satisfying and
then the way it works is like you go
through a bunch of these rooms it's like
binding of isaac in a lot of ways where
you go through a bunch of rooms and then
you get up to a mini boss and then once
you've completed that mini boss there's
a narrative thing where it usually kicks
you out and then you do some stuff in
the in the open world not the opposite
the resource management stuff clean up
some poop you know
yeah you need that along the you eat it
make the poop into some porridge or some
[ __ ] and
some pervert wants to eat it
um but like and then and then like you
you also like during the dungeon bits
you sometimes will come upon like it's
like that thing where you you pick a
pathway through each each point and when
you're picking your pathway through each
dungeon you'll have like an icon where
it's like there's a man on this icon or
a person on this icon it's like oh
that's a follower or there's like a
resource icon or a weapon icon and you
can like pick your path through it and
if you go through like the person icon
you rescue a follower which when you go
back to the um the resource management
part of your town you can indoctrinate
and have them do things um you know like
you can set them to
uh worship and there's like a a statue
at the center where anyone who sits
there and prays it kind of feeds into a
resource that then you can
absorb and spend on like edicts or
whatever it may be like doing certain
things to make your cult more culty
um or you can just like
spend loads loads of runs going through
it again you know collecting resources
and eventually you go through one
dungeon enough times that you'll get to
the end boss and then once you wipe that
dungeon it's pretty much done you need
to kill four bosses to like unshackle an
old one who has like given you your
power um but you can carry on going back
to those dungeons that you've already
done and each when you go in there the
enemies are like more powerful so you
can like resource grind which is really
cool yeah there's also like some more
stuff to unlock because there's various
decorations you can and buildings you
can place
in your little cult land yeah there's
also
a tarot deck
and they are basically game modifiers
and so i have a
an ability because of the fleece that
i'm wearing that at the start of every
time i go into a dungeon i automatically
get four tarot cards
and then but they're completely random
whereas normally if you're doing the
dungeon caller you get to pick what your
your um
your cards are and so
i just want to have like give myself a
little bit more of a leg up at the very
beginning but i don't get to choose oh
yeah god sorry
let's get the [ __ ] out of me it's a very
mechanically dense game like it keeps
throwing
but like it's it's all mechanics that
make you
like dribble a bit when you sit down and
just like ah i'm just going to play this
game for a little longer and
like yeah you know it's like zone out
and and like you just you like it
catches you in the loop and it's so
satisfying and like it has to be stated
like you can't overstate how
well the the uh
the cutesy koi aesthetic works it's such
a good contrast because you have people
just doing and saying the most heinous
[ __ ] but everyone's cute so you're like
oh yes i will cut your head off and bury
you that's cool um i had a question
about the twitch integration because i
kee i keep seeing everyone talk about it
what does the twitch integration do
exactly
you get um so whenever you get a new
follower hey bubba um
you get to uh basically people i think
they get to opt in and then they get to
be named as a member of your cult
yeah
become an actual follower they become
like an npc
in your that's so cool so yeah
yeah when you when you get a follower um
you can actually like set what they look
like and you can like reshape them like
i've turned everyone in everyone who
regards who i find turn them into a fox
and change their color so like i've got
a cult of all foxes yeah and you can
like name them and and each one has like
likes and dislikes and you can listen to
them like you can see their thoughts and
stuff like that sometimes you'll walk up
to someone and be like let me check what
their thoughts are it's like i really
wish i was eating poop right now and
you're like okay clearly this person
wants to eat poop um
but like there's various things and you
have to do things like daily you can
give them blessings and every now and
then like you'll get dissenters who like
appear and they're like screaming in a
megaphone about how the cult is bad and
stuff and you can make decisions that
are like i could spend a few days just
keep giving this person blessings until
like you you've brought them back over
to your side or you can chuck them in
jail or you can just kill them and it's
like you can do one of those things but
each one has consequences obviously the
longer route is where you give them
blessings but you risk their message
kind of carrying further
but the shorter one if you just outright
kill them you might make a lot of people
nervous and doubt you and so like
there's this kind of like really nice i
guess synergy between certain mechanics
um and like like i said the the resource
management base building stuff and the
combat stuff in the dungeons isn't like
super super like connected but it's it
all works so well and so smoothly that
you just don't really i just don't
really care i'm just like this is these
are two good games in one game and it's
cute as hell and it's like really nice
fun right writing um and unlike there's
on the steam deck there's just a button
which you press and the sh the uh lam
bleats so i just run around
in people's faces and that's like
hilarious to me
um yes i was noticing too there's like
bosses are kind of in 3d not just 2d so
when you're like in a
3d arena like
i'm looking at a video right now of like
this this mouth monster and it looks so
like with trees coming out of its head
it looks so cool yeah i love the art
style because it's just such a perfect
mix of just really cute but then
especially in the bosses but also when
you are doing the rituals it just goes
from zero to [ __ ] up
yeah it like yeah it is and like you get
all these cute little animals walk into
your little church and then you select
ritual and then suddenly out of nowhere
they all put on these like [ __ ]
occultist hoods and they like get in a
circle and you're like that was that was
a bit creepy but
we met that mushroom pervert yeah yeah
it's got like loads of cool fun
characters and it's just like i i would
like i didn't expect it but it's it's
like one of my favorite games of the
year so far and it's like easily like i
feel like you can get a good feel for
whether you're going to enjoy it within
an hour
yeah and there's a demo out of it so out
for it so like make sure you just check
out the demo at the very least because
chances are you're probably gonna like
it and it runs well on steam deck other
than there's one area where you go into
and it's like a side scrolling area and
it gets a bit choppy
but it's like you're not in there that
much and it's easy to deal with
did mikko just get fed there yeah did
you hear that yeah it's like i thought
it was mine
her auto a food auto dispenser just
um started dispensing food and she she
doesn't care these days she's just like
yeah
um
yeah i think i think she's realized that
no one else is going to eat that food so
she can take her time
before she'll be like oh my god this
food i got to get there before anyone
else well now she's just like
no it's this [ __ ] human amy in it
um yeah anything else lucy uh so i
watched all of so i i'm in the middle of
watching it's not bird box black bird on
apple tv which is taran eggerton
edgerton uh it's a really cool premise
apparently based on a true story
a friend of the show andrew goldfarb
recommended it
and it's very much hitting scratching
that mind hunter itch that i've been
having where i want some kind of gritty
crime drama but it's basically taran
taran edgerton elton john himself um
drug dealer who gets sent to prison for
10 years and they say that he they will
get rid of his sentence if he transfers
to um
more like a
an asylum where um they're kind of uh
mentally ill patients and if he gets one
guy to confess to a string of murders to
basically tell them where the bodies are
of all these young women
based on a true story which i'm not i'm
not looking into too much but the guy
who plays um
larry who also has a
twin called gary um
it's terrifying he's so good
it's uh and like taran and er eggette
edgeton as well like
i i understand why people say that he's
in the running for wolverine because
he's ridiculously buff in this but it's
also like prison prison dramas are never
normally my thing because i actually
genuinely find prison very very scary
um especially there's one no no there's
one like because my mom used to work
essentially in the prison service and so
she would just tell me these stories
about what it'd be like and for a while
i wanted to be a criminal um
psychologist and she was like they will
eat you up and just spit you out do not
[ __ ] do it so
and also there was it there was a show
in the uk last year
with sean bean
and he was he got put in prison and it
was just like the naught to 100 on riots
and there was a riot scene in blackbird
which [ __ ] terrified me it was like
something out of watchmen and it was
just
oh but anyway it was it's a really good
show it's only six episodes
um
and it's on apple tv but my main thing
in time i know you've been watching
sandman
yeah i've been watching one episode a
day because i'm yeah i've been like
trying to relish it oh yes at six i
think six or six you got through 24
hours yeah i got 24. they call it 24 7
in this one
which is weird but um yeah
quite different from
somehow less harrowing than the comic
version but still pretty hopeful
yeah
if you if you want to see a real list of
all the big changes in sandman head over
to gamescore.com because
like a little freak yeah so for people
who don't know this the the concept in
sandman is there's a character called
john d who has
one of morpheus's like relics and he
goes into a diner and basically it's the
entire story morpheus is not even in the
sandman's not in it it's like 24 hours
in that diner with this guy basically
turning the lives of everyone in there
upside down
and it is
awful like it is it is
so horrifying but you read it and you're
like this is some [ __ ] top tier like
it's one of the best comic book issues
like
stories ever ever written i think like
it's perfect top front above but you're
like oh it's amazing um but it's also
harrowing to watch and they do a pretty
good job of of kind of um
adapting it for the tv show the only
thing about it is like
john d as a character in the comics is
way more like scary to me
in the comic he's like
you can't see his face that much you
just see he's basically like a husk of a
person yeah he's been in that's the
other thing is like there are some
concessions they had to make because
they can't use places like arkham asylum
they couldn't use john constantine it is
constantine or constantine uh
constantine so they've swapped for
joanna
but like there is a modern joanna and
obviously the lady joanna constantine
who plays a role in a much later sandman
arc um
but like
yeah the the john d the john d stuff and
they also got david thulis to play him
which i think i think he's a very
he's a very unusual actor and he's the
kind of person that every time he's on
screen i'm always drawn to him
and i think he does a great job as john
d but it is it is very different
but i think it really works
it also has as as i'm going go ahead i
was going to say that episode was really
good
i loved the
one about death i won't say too much
just in case people are still watching
but but they're their favorite there's
some really good singular episodes in
this show but i think some of the
earlier episodes that i was a little i
don't know about yeah
and those i'd actually read like i've
read
i forget how far i got into sandman but
i at least read those first couple with
what's supposed to be john constantine
um and and i enjoyed those but i never
and i never finished it um
so i was kind of on the fence on those
but those
there's like three episodes near the end
that with hob too i really like that
episode i thought that was really cool
yeah it's it's i think it's a really
good show so far the first few episodes
are a bit slow there's a couple of
like there's one week episode of them so
far and i think it is the joanna
constantine once sadly because and it's
sad because like that whole story
is one of my favorites in the comic um
well they they bring up um so even even
in the comic when john constantine and
sandman together it's to get back
morpheus's bag of sand
and it's just a kind of one one issue
where they get together and um it turns
out that like john's junkie
ex-girlfriend stole it i liked the
changes they made to that um but i also
like the fact that john in the in the
comic is suffering from nightmares
because of an incident uh at the
casanova club which is a part of a
when he was in a different group and
it's based in newcastle which is where
i'm from and there were actual jordies
and they fleshed that out and showed it
in the show and actually had proper
geordie actors in so i really enjoyed it
for that but then they do stuff with
joanna and um
in the sandman and i just
i'm not gonna lie i had no interest in
this show until you guys told me about
it because i
dude it was it was advertised to all
hell at san diego comic con and i had no
idea
what it was about or what it was but now
hearing you guys talk about it yeah i'm
gonna watch it tonight it it it feels it
feels very
it's more arty than you might think
because i think the the the kind of like
superhero supernatural dc connection is
what leads a lot of people into thinking
it's something different i don't know
how you realize yeah that was
that it was connected to that yeah yeah
it's in the dc universe
like i had no idea
i had no idea scarecrows in it yeah
batman is referenced at points well john
d is actually captured by the justice
league the justice league yeah and like
there's a whole bunch of different
things that happen and like they talk
they make a lot of references to to like
the wider dc universe and obviously
constantine is a dc hero right or
anti-hero um that keanu reeves movie
constantine underrated
i've watched every night i enjoyed it
i love that movie it's fun it's good and
also like the tv the tv show underrated
like for for a solid
run of it it's like i enjoyed most of it
um
how come they weren't able to use those
dc characters was it because of rights
because it is produced by warner bros
isn't it
it's weird so i don't know about arkham
asylum but neil gaiman did say that the
rights with john are tied up
but apparently they'd all apparently
they'd all always plan to make it joanna
okay because it ties dramatically to
those i think i saw a quote that they
were working on another constantine
thing and they didn't want to confuse
people with
two different constantines back to back
or something i don't know but
yeah i i
i assumed the reason we didn't see a lot
of those characters or hear about them
was because
wb didn't have any involvement but then
i've started the first episode and wb
shows up and i'm like okay so
where are they yeah
100
you're gone no go ahead uh well no um
sweden just has house cw energy
no not at all as someone who has watched
a lot of cw shows it doesn't have that
minute you say when the minute you say
does it have cw energy i immediately go
great i don't need to watch it but like
no no it doesn't happen it doesn't
happen honestly it's good it's got yeah
but the actual show has got like some
really stunning like environments and
and like set piece moments and
i just had the the battle in hell for
example that i really really liked
this game yeah the oldest game uh and
like that was really really cool um
i it's it's a completely different thing
than cw is nothing like it at all um
yeah i think i think part of it is that
like
neil gaiman is obviously very involved
but the like the guy who plays morpheus
is a huge fan and i think morpheus as a
character is very difficult to get right
i think james mcavoy is great in the
audible thing because but then you know
you are you're essentially playing this
[ __ ] trent reznor ass goth who's
he's endless that's the whole thing like
he's dream of the endless how do you
convey that and i think the clever thing
that tom sturridge does is that like he
constantly looks like he's about to cry
i mean in a good way he just always
looks like he's seen too [ __ ] much
yes he he
the way i think of it is like he is
looking into the void at all points like
he doesn't look like he's present in
most conversations entirely he always
looks like he's got one eye on the thing
that is in front of him and one eye on
this like horrifying endless void behind
everything like it's it's like really
fascinating the way he does it and like
there's moments where you can tell
it's really subtle but like he takes a
bit too long to reply to some characters
and he takes a bit too long to like
react to things and
what initially starts off as feeling
quite weird eventually you realize oh
this is a person who's like or this is a
being that is like
everywhere at all at once and is like
this is a trifling thing for him and the
fact that a person is able to do that so
well is really really interesting and
the way he speaks as well there's like a
slow kind of droning methodical way
speech where his speech comes out where
you're like this person is like
spellbinding in a way and it's like it's
100 worth watching um it doesn't it's
not like perfect but as far as like a
live action adaptation thus far i think
it's pretty good i never imagined it
would happen like and actually be good
one thing i'll find one final thing that
i will say is that um the person who
plays desire mason alexander park i
believe their name is
[ __ ] outstanding they are desire and
desire is an absolute menace of a
character always interfering in
everyone's affairs and stuff but at the
same time they are very
just like
just sexy as they're doing it and and uh
the actor they found is absolutely
perfect and i and i think that's one of
the show's real like strongest part is
the casting like the uh boyd
what's his name he plays the corinthian
like the corinthian is just in a couple
of issues but they've they've stretched
him out so they make him like kind of
the big bad person
and um
yeah i think it's and lighter hall and
hector and
the gang they're great i really like
matthew the crow a lot
yeah
yeah patton oswald as matthew's great um
but yeah it's also an extremely british
show like the amount of british actors
on this and say i was telling lucy like
we had a in the in the uk we had a
comedy show called goodness gracious me
and it was south asian-led so there's a
lot of indian people and pretty much the
entire cast of goodness gracious me an
extremely niche
comedy show sketch show is in this show
and i was like i was watching it i was
like i remember you from goodness
gracious me and then the next episode i
was like i remember you from connecticut
yeah yeah and then i was like they're
only missing this one person now and
then she shows up in the next scene and
i was like what the [ __ ] is going on
also there's like a a i told lucy about
this but like there's a there's a uk
kind of like a comedian who who
basically he's he's a
he didn't like blow up in a major way he
started off on instagram and he he came
up as a
parody rapper called unknown p and he's
basically his whole thing was he would
pretend as if he's like high society
tory rapper and he'd rap about stuff
that the one percenters could only
relate to like having a lot of money his
name is munya chihuahua um and uh he's
he also does sketches about like
political sketches and he's in this show
and like when he appeared on screen i
was like
that's money i didn't realize he was and
i went back and he like announced it a
little while ago and it's like just
amazing to see like a bunch of british
people in this show in netflix
production so yeah super good highly
recommend it
um
before we move on quickly gerard
i i recommended a couple of anime to you
can i get an anime update
yes i am i okay
so i've been watching mob is it mob
psycho
yeah
i got i got three episodes in and i love
it um i i've been on the road a lot so i
haven't had a chance to sit down but
like now that i'm home
i'm going to start watching it again
i love it it's great it gives me exactly
what i wanted from
uh one punch man and uh
for those of you guys who don't know i'm
not a big anime guy i've only really
enjoyed not yet i've only really enjoyed
one punch man and so uh
damn recommended uh mop psycho to me and
i've been really really enjoying it same
energy same vibe but obviously very
different yeah i'm i'm i'm gerard's one
anime sherpa yeah i'm waiting for you to
get through one punch man and by the
time that's out
by the time you're done with that
chances are chainsaw men will be out and
i think you'll enjoy that yeah
i'm ready
all right let's move on to the next and
uh final segment of this podcast we'll
make it quick just because we've been
talking for way longer than i expected
but in honor of gerard's show the god of
work in which he plays kratos the god of
war in an office environment i thought
wouldn't it be fun to go through the
so we've got two options here we can
either go through the
personality types of the characters in
the office
and try and reassign them to video game
characters or who they would be or we
can go through the 11 types of office
jobs and try and come up with people to
focus on those jobs which one would you
prefer i don't watch the office so yeah
i watched the office but i think yeah i
think the second minute since i watched
the okay
okay so we'll do the rolls these are
extremely niche so this is going to be
either absolutely awful or hilarious i'm
ready number one
accounts payable clerk
okay what is that
their primary duties are
monitor and process incoming payments
for an organization their
responsibilities include learning about
and tracking compliance regulations and
the state and federal laws following
company mandated protocols to process
incoming payments and performing
transaction on behalf of organizations
so basically the person who makes sure
everyone gets paid okay what video game
character could be an account payable
clerk is there a is there a character
that like
requires souls or must harvest souls
from people
hmm
there are many of those
there's raziel from soulriver
who like ah so who who wants to oh no
you know i've got it i've got it um do
you remember that [ __ ] bear from
spyro the dragon who looked like a
little hoity-toity monopoly man
for you unless you paid him a certain
amount of gems that [ __ ]
what was that guy's name i
um
spyro
is it is it too easy to say tom nook
nook
it's money bags according to the spyro
wiki hmm
i kind of like tom nook is a good one
tom look or even isabelle maybe
i was gonna say now i i
i feel like isabelle might be good for
the next one okay okay but like as when
it comes to like
because accounts payable clerks also
have to like prepare financial
information they work on bills invoices
bank deposits and that kind of [ __ ] so i
feel like tom nook would be
that person he'd be on everyone's ass
and he would make sure no one's like
spending money unnecessarily i was gonna
say this isn't really a character but
like the person you play in papers
please
oh yeah i feel like that could be also
good for another one but they're not
really i don't know they're like kind of
a character but not really
yeah sadly in this weird universe that
we created tom nook would be getting
paid an average national salary of
thirty thousand thirty five thousand
dollars oh
big yike um well he's he's extorting a
community
as a side job
number two data entry clerk data entry
clerks create update and format data
sets for an organization they do is
include collecting data from sources
such as surveys sales information
primary sources internal and external to
the organization sector resources
so basically
typing in and organizing that stuff who
that's what i feel isabelle would be
good for
is it better
because someone else might have gotten
it wrong
top um that that is a great choice i
think we've nailed that one yeah
number three receptionist
collects information and greets visitors
to an office duties include answering
emails and telephone calls directed to
an office providing another layer of
security for office buildings and i
don't know if the receptionist should be
providing layers of security this feels
i don't know why i went there
in smash man
my first thought is that [ __ ] owl in
ocarina of time that like shows up oh
yeah
just [ __ ] yeah freedom cop as i like
to call him
he's like where are you going
huh
yeah do you want to hear it again do you
want to hear it again do you want to
join it again
yeah that owl is a great show do we want
isabelle do we want ocarina i think we
should keep it to like one per yeah i
feel like animal crossing character
could fill every one of these so we're
going to give it to the owl from ocarina
yeah
um
mail clerk
male clerks are this one's easy this
one's easy
mail clicks are professionals who
monitor and root mail to the correct
recipients in
uh in an office they do is include
dating incoming and outgoing mail
weighing packages to determine uh
postage recording mail for other
professionals in the office and using
fax and scanning machines to create
digital copies of physical mail
who'd you reckon
is it an enchantment
guy
no this is so you have to copy things
this is a this is a sam porter bridges
joint
[Music]
[Laughter]
the mailman from ocarina of time just
seems too easy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i feel like sam porter bridge is
the one for this one
i'd love to see him fully kitted out
just walking around an office
all stumbling around
i used to be me that genuinely used to
be my job
i love the idea of sample bridges using
a zip line to go from like one room to
the other room when you could like get
there in three seconds how about the the
courier from skyrim who somehow always
bugged and would only be in his
underwear whenever he'd approach you
with mail
i think i think he gets fired pretty
quickly i think
yes
we all know why he gets fired but yeah
exactly
but i also love the idea of him
appearing randomly and just co-opting
every conversation where he when he
appears like the camera zooms in on him
and you're like oh my god he's here is
there an intern as an option is that a a
thing
we can add intern to it because i was
going to say the adoring fan from from
oblivion as the intern yeah
that's a great one
got your coffee here mr grand champion
office manager primary duties include
controlling the processes inside an
office setting they have duties such as
scheduling meetings and appointments
with other professionals in the
organization ordering new equipment for
the office and organizing the layout to
maximize productivity repairing or
replacing damage equipment if we're
being honest it's probably glados i was
gonna say oh yes yes
and office managers can have like a very
malicious streak to them as well so oh
yeah so glados is pretty much perfect
yeah
um
let's go to
uh
what is this
executive assistant
provide support to top-level executives
within an organization responsibilities
include scheduling for executives that
they represent responding to emails for
them and calls for them training new
members of staff on office protocols and
meets with the executive when they need
who's in the
yes as annoying yeah hey
listen
yeah we've already done zelda though so
i don't know i'm trying to
wait i was gonna say like lydia
from skyrim oh yeah yeah more ghana
time to go to bed time to go to bed um
boss and to go to bed or like uh
like one of the velvet attendants
oh yeah uh twins or elizabeth uh yeah
justine elizabeth but they're very very
aggressive they like hit you and stuff
so it's like
they'll get fired very quickly
hey we're not trying to figure out how
long they last yeah
someone said the girl from bioshock the
little sister i guess i think is that
what they're called little sisters
little sister
yeah but they're like also kind of a bit
murderous um a final one customer
service representative professionals who
support the needs of an organization's
customers their duties include learning
about the products and services and
company offers i got it you got it who
you got
the merchant from from
services on sale stranger although i
like the idea of like a
call center but it's just a vending
machine with like
yeah like a headset to it
just come back when you got some money
buddy
all right cool wait i'm trying to make a
return come back when you're going to
get some money buddy
that would be great
and there you have it we have
successfully cast
a office full of video game characters
which what is what you can see when you
tune into god of work on g4
um later this month or on the
completionist youtube channel where
you'll be able to watch all the episodes
binge watch it or if you want to do the
slow release
the slow satisfying release you go to g4
gerard
anything else you want to say about your
your baby god of work oh man uh i hope
you guys really like it it's it's really
a love letter to video games and to the
developers who make them and uh
if you like the office even if you don't
like the office yeah i think you're
gonna have a good time with it and uh
again just a big thank you to you guys
for having me this was really fun
uh really honored that you had me and
were willing to let me showcase our dumb
little show that hopefully uh everyone
watches so thanks again
i'm back anytime
thank you
uh jake where you at what what are you
up to
i'm covering a game coming out soon so i
guess you'll probably see videos for
that i talked about that uh art of war
video that is coming along it's gonna
take a while though so bear with me on
that one hopefully it'll be worth it
um those are the main things some
smaller stuff here and there
oh no i think i'll be running the
podcast so we'll see if it makes sense
yeah i was gonna say uh you can find me
at john like safety but you will get
nothing from me because i'm going on a
break for the next week
wonderful
lucy
uh
twitter etc uh lucy james games what am
i working on
uh we've got a new episode of i heart
gaming coming out if you're listening on
friday uh or if you're watching live
it's coming out tomorrow it's about
metal gear solid
um
and then in turn we've got jeff just our
adventure next week
i'm doing a lot of stuff on a lot of
things that are coming out later but i
am very much
around
like a bad smell
bye
okay um i'm at tomorrow everywhere
twitch uh twitter
uh i don't do any work here so you can
find me out everywhere else yes tam the
least hardest worker in all cases that
is me uh draw it before we go can you
just tell people where people can find
you as well yeah you can find me on
twitch.tv the completionist or my
youtube channel youtube.com
that1videogamer uh you can also find me
on on twitch.tv g4tv or youtube.com
xplay
uh where i am
reviewing games completing games
playing games non-stop i don't sleep i
just play games i'm a i'm a machine
help me i need to change my batteries
thank you for listening
thank you everyone for joining us we'll
see you again next week goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you